as-tu déjà triché lors d'un examen
il y a longtemps as-tu peur de la mort
je suppose que je ne suis pas enthousiasmé par ça, alors
oui, es-tu ami avec Elon Musk
euh je l'aime bien euh je pense qu'il fait un excellent
travail et moi non  je le connais très bien est-ce que
tu commandes sur Amazon I
j'achète beaucoup de livres sur Amazon
crois-tu que tu as plus de pouvoir que Joe
Biden aujourd'hui non tu regrettes d'avoir quitté
Harvard non tu crois que peut-être que la socratie
existe aujourd'hui
dans une certaine mesure ok tu crois
Eminem est un bon président pour lutter contre le
changement climatique. Moi, Barack Obama était un
bon président
euh il était bon à bien des égards euh vous
savez, j'aimerais que chaque président soit aussi
bon que lui.